fresh attacks inside North Syria even as
the u.s. presidential envoys scrambled
to Turkey to talk peace the Fighting's
as fierce as ever and Turkish troops are
being ordered to keep on firing there's
zero appetite amongst the Turkish for
stopping this offensive in Ankara the
president told his party's MPs that
below ceasefire until the Turkish YPG
pulled back 35 kilometers from the
border unless we reach that objective no
power can stop us he said to those who
threaten us with economic sanctions he
went on you will lose more than we do
[Applause]
[Music]
and telling America you can starve us
with your sanctions we will never give
in the US delegation has a tough
challenge ahead the presidents clearly
irritated with the American
administration telling the crowd they
say one thing to our face and another
behind our back thank you I'm based in
Istanbul but I'm from Sky News in
Britain when we spoke to him minutes
afterwards he was relaxed but had this
sting for the incoming US officials the
American delegation was coming here are
you worried about it will you be seeing
American dinner girls from the village
in Chains
why would we concerned about what will
you be saying to them in another issue
sure I'm standing I'm not thanks doctor
unlock our study leadership they will be
talking their counterparts
when Trump comes here I'll be talking
that suggested he wouldn't meet the US
vice president who's hoping to persuade
him on a ceasefire was this intended to
put the u.s. on the backfoot
it caused a huge concern and shortly
afterwards he told Turkish journalists
he would see the Pens Pompeo delegation
his summit with Trump next month will
depend on how those talks go he said so
far the Americans aren't having much
luck the US National Security Advisor
breezed in to see the Turkish Foreign
Minister but those talks didn't happen
rescheduled not canceled was how the
officials put it although he did see two
key advisors instead in Washington
President Trump played down the crisis I
think our vice president is a very
capable man will do well tomorrow he's
going to meet with President Erdogan /
president there no one said he wouldn't
meet with anybody and he took that back
just a little while ago and he said no I
will and I think they'll have a
successful meeting and on the
battlefield in North Syria the Russians
are moving in where American soldiers
were and one world leader the Turkish
president will see is Russia's President
Putin in a few weeks time Alex Crawford
Sky News Turkey